and another big story this morning the
Supreme Court has blocked a
controversial abortion law just hours
before it was to go into effect it was a
five to four vote last night that
temporarily blocked the Louisiana law
that critics say would force two of the
state's three abortion clinics to close
Jan Crawford is at the Supreme Court
with how this order unfolded Jen it's
always great to have you on a morning
like this on such an important case tell
us how it went down thanks Nora and good
morning I mean obviously this could be
the first test of abortion rights in the
Supreme Court with new conservative
justices it involves a 2014 Louisiana
law that required abortion clinic
doctors to have admitting privileges at
nearby hospitals now in 2016 the Supreme
Court struck down a nearly identical law
from Texas on a 5 to 3 vote but last
night
conservative Chief Justice John Roberts
sided with the Liberals in this case to
stop the law from taking effect while
the court considers whether it's going
to take up this case the courts for
conservative justices including new
justice Brett Kavanaugh dissented
justice Cavanaugh wrote separately to
say he would allow the law to take
effect for now but he could be willing
to rethink it if it showed that it had
that undue burden on a woman's right to
get an abortion
now this like you said is just temporary
it may not tell us much of anything
about how the courts going to approach
abortion rights the justices still have
to decide whether they're going to hear
this case they could do so next fall
John Jan thank you so much for breaking
it down for us